90 millions d'Américains sont sous le
coup d'une alerte aux hautes
températures ici à Phoenix en Arizona 47
degrés attendus les concerts en
extérieur sont annulés c'est le 16e jour
consécutif au-dessus de 43 degrés les
gens ne comprennent pas que la chaleur
est très dangereuse on doit mener des
opérations de secours il y a des gens
qui croient qu'une petite randonnée
facile qu'ils peuvent le faire mais s'il
fait 46 degrés dehors ça peut monter
jusqu'à 60 degrés au sol Sandrine
Rousseau au début d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts qui twitaient à 48 heures on va
revoir son tweet il fait 60 degrés en
Espagne 60 degrés alors là pour le coup
on est dans la caricature en Espagne on
attend des pointes à 42 degrés au
désespoir des pompiers aux Canaries à La
Palma 2500 habitants ont dû être évacués
lis les ravagé par les feux qui avec le
vent progressent vite alors là oui on
est clairement dans la caricature faut
savoir que ce que mentionne Sandrine
Rousseau a juste titre il fait bien 60
degrés à la surface
du sol ce qui peut provoquer des dégâts
au niveau du sol après je le rappelle en
Espagne on n'a pas du tout le même
climat le même sol et la même végétation
pourrait également voir dépasser la plus
haute température de l'air jamais
enregistrée sur la planète c'était au
même endroit en 2021
54,4 degrés le Canada impuissant face à
ses gigantesques incendies qui dévorent
le pays depuis le mois de mai 10
millions d'hectares ont brûlé cette
année un bilan sans précédent
les rafales et les pluies de grêle
dévastatrice ont débuté vers 17h hier
provoquant de nombreux dégâts regardez
plutôt ces températures record 48 degrés
notamment en Iran 49 en Tunisie 48 en
Sicile en Sardaigne 35 en Allemagne
jusqu'à 54 degrés en Californie la
Sardaigne la Sicile c'est là que des
records pourraient être battus dans les
prochains jours le dernier record la
chaleur la plus forte jamais enregistrée
c'était 48,8 degrés en Sicile à l'été
2021 en Corée du Sud en pleine mousson
d'été au moins 33 personnes sont mortes
10 autres portées disparus après les
fortes pluies qui ont provoqué
inondations glissement de terrain et
débordement d'un important barrage plus
au sud au Maroc les météorologues
prévoient jusqu'à 47 degrés 40 ont été
relevés en Jordanie conséquence du
dérèglement climatique Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a dénoncé la jonction dans les
faits entre le camp macroniste et
l'extrême droite il fustige un ramassis
Rance de tous les réactionnaires et qui
sait selon lui consolider durant les
émeutes en Californie des surfeurs
évoluent dans l'eau au milieu d'un grand
requin blanc alors eux ne le voit pas
c'est un drone qui a capté la scène la
semaine dernière deux attaques ont eu
lieu le même jour près de New York et il
parle d'un racisme intrinsèque à la
police le racisme dans la police et
dorénavant une cause reconnue par les
gens normaux le mot violence policière
est passé dans le vocabulaire plus
courant la population
ose dire de qui elle a davantage peur
est désormais quand je suis le mur du
con voilà bon ça y est bon ça y est il
est il est super sonique maintenant en
réalité pratique deux choses à mon avis
la première ce qu'on appelle la
rhétorique du vide et puis ces
inscriptions antisémites et néo-nazies
découvertes sur un monument commémorant
la résistance à ploa clermitage dans les
Côtes-d'Armor érigé en mémoire de 55
personnes exécutées par les nazis durant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale demande s'il
y a pas en lui une haine successorale et
s'il ne cherche pas par ces excès par
ces outrances à
miner complètement la succession Jane
Birkin qui s'est éteinte ce dimanche
elle avait 76 ans c'est une icône de la
chanson et du cinéma qui nous a quitté
elle a été retrouvée sans vie à son
domicile parisien elle avait récemment
annulé des concerts en raison de son
état de santé puisqu'elle avait
notamment su bien l'AVC en 2021